améliore de ce que vous préférez en vous
et bien que c'est chez personne
que j'ai un truc qui va pas je m'en
l'arrangent et toi dirait que tu me fais
chier alors eh ben les brugeois puis
c'est tout et puis et puis c'est ça que
je veux dire ce que vous détestez en
vous écoutez je suis pas mal je suis pas
méchante geipan mieux' je pourrais dire
fils [ __ ] jeu jamais teens alain une
belle [ __ ] qui fait qu'on tue les
mets ça qu'il ne fait pas ce que vous
préférez dans le cinéma le cinéma bonnes
réponses que vous détestez dans le
cinéma données plus fiables cinéma je
suis malheureuse
mais j'adore le théâtre
mais le cinéma pour moi c'est devenu
une évidence je pense qu'il était beau
cinéma autant au théâtre
diack en juin mario ici une chose
mais au cinéma
tout donné
tu peux dans les émotions tu vas dans
les choses que tu as donné tu peux les
données peut les donner aux ruines a
battu va donner pourquoi des gens
m'écrivent pourquoi ils me disent
pourquoi ce que les ai touché sur
quelque chose
c'est à dire que comme ça tu vas langage
il te comprennent ils te comprennent et
écrivent le plus grand moment de votre
vie
alors maintenant
mais bon la naissance
de grands moments qu'est ce que c'est
des moments c'est des moments de d'amour
oui je parle d'abord ma fille de d'avoir
le bonheur d'avoir eu cette mère que
j'ai eu mon frère un milieu plus au
moment de votre vie le débarquement ah
ouais ouais ouais
parce que j'ai peur depuis ce jour là ce
que vous préférez dans la vie
j'aime bien rigoler ouais
j'ai envie de fumer je fume un j'aurais
jamais rien parce que j'ai dit que je
leur ai rien et puis c'est tout faux
parce qu'à l'idée ce que vous détestez
dans la vie les gens qui font grincheux
et six mois
de plus belle nuit avec un homme
oui c'était pas forcément des nuits mais
on n'attendait pas
les gens qui arrivent et qui ce parc
drame et après est votre pire nuit avec
un homme
bon c'est pas possible
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu